can ask the public gallery not to sing
hearts down Park is down the road if you
want to support your local football team
I'd advise you to go there when they're
playing but not in the chamber thank you
if we carry on like that I'll up the
public gallery emptied and you can shout
outside thank you good evening members
and officers of the council and members
of the press and public you're welcome I
welcome you to this meeting of the
council if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices via the stairs
either through the security doors to my
right or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in holy square on the green
officers will assist you and advise
whether it is deemed safe to return to
the chamber the Proceedings of this
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening thank you very much in that
case any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress thank you agenda
item 1 apologies for absence apologists
have been received from councillors Lim
Fairbrass
Falkon Larkin's metaphase pew
Shroomish nursing Hillman de brim and
Braidwood and bambridge are there any
other apologies councillor Roy Potts
please him Thank You councillor Piper
agenda item two minutes of previous
meeting held on the 6th of September
2018 I move that the minutes of the
meeting of the Council held on the 6th
of September 2018 be approved and signed
as a correct record with the vice
chairman please second
are you a councillor well you can you
can see the minutes on the TDC website
once you learn to maneuver your way
through the system but the minutes will
be there can I have that seconded
vice-chairman a second deck chair thank
you do members agree thank you agenda
item three announcements it is with
regret that I have to announce that the
former councillor Trevor Eames has
recently passed away
Mr Eames was a liberal Democrat
councillor and mayor of Broadstairs and
some Peters I'm sure council will join
me in expressing sympathy to mr. Ames's
family could all members please stand
for a minute silence as he mark a
respect for the late mr. Aames
thank you
I was just about councilor hatin I was
just about to say does any member wish
to say a few words Kelso hatin thank you
very much chairman good evening
Trevor Larry Ames was a very good
counselor for Broadstairs and st.
Peter's Town Council also in this
chamber he was very good district
counselor he we both shared the business
of the breast award in Broadstairs
obviously we didn't always see eye to
eye but mostly we did and quite frankly
he said yeah that's poor old whoever's
gone and I miss him well thank you very
much Jim
Thank You councillor hate and kilts law
yes Johnson that's me thank you
I'd like to obviously often offer our
sympathy to Trevor's family
there aren't many counselors here now
who actually will remember him but
obviously Bob you to recall him but for
me it was the fun we had at folk week
and other events because he wasn't just
a district councillor or the mayor of
Broadstairs he was very involved as
where his family in all the life of
Fallot and in particular to say the folk
we can remember with great affection and
I think that we should always mark the
passing of our councillors no matter how
long ago it is because sometimes people
are forgotten and I'd like to be noted
too that we on the labor side send our
deepest sympathy to his family thank you
Thank You council Johnson um I wasn't a
counselor when he sat in this chamber
but I did get involved with Trevor in
Broadstairs and in addition to his work
with the folk week he was very actively
in the Dickens Festival and one of his
things that he organised was the the
cricket the the Dickensian cricket on
Victoria Gardens back in the days when
we had proper teams and as I remember in
order to get into the cricket team you
needed to go through a trial now
the Broadstairs redstone Ian's who
regularly played the teachers and
lecturers from then sanic College so yes
he was very very active and yes it's a
set party no other members wish to speak
I'll then move on to agenda item 4 which
is declarations of interest are there
any declarations of interest in
association with this evenings agenda no
declarations of interest gender item 5
is petitions no petitions have been
received in accordance with the council
procedure number 12
gender item 6 questions from the press
and public one question has been
received from the member of the public
in accordance with council procedure
rule number 13 please note that only the
questioner and respondent are permitted
to speak on the question and that if the
questioner is not present at this
meeting their question cannot be put but
will be replied to in writing could the
questionnaire please only state the name
of the cabinet members whom their
question is to be put and read out the
exact wording of the question that they
submitted to Council so agenda item 6a
is question number 1 and the only
question that we have this evening and
that's with regards to street cleaning
around some John's Road and Adventist
Street I'm pleased to welcome as white
to the meeting could you please make
your way to the top table thank you very
much and your question is my question is
for councillor Savage
what steps are being taken to clean the
streets around Crawley square the only
time the square and Addington Street a
free of litter is when I carry out a
little pick myself the area outside st.
John's Road is a particular concern with
dumped mattresses and other rubbish
thank you this one well we'll put I call
upon the counselor savage to respond
councillor savage thank you very much
Sharon good evening miss white thank you
for your question and I have an answer
for you first and foremost a manual
sweeper does clean Hawley square and
daily the mechanical sweeper also
attends this area after 9:00 a.m.
five days out of seven a week it does so
at this time at the request of residents
due to the noise it can make this
presents a problem as the square is not
fully accessible to clean after 9 a.m.
due to park cars if residents are
prepared for us to use mechanical
sweepers between the hours of 6 & 8 we
stand a better chance of getting the
streets more thoroughly cleaned perhaps
you could let us know on that position
we are looking at trialing some
pedestrian sweeping machines which are
able to clean pavements and smaller
spaces funds have been made available by
the council to purchase this type of
equipment in the 2019 2020 years the
bulky waste collection vehicle clicks
any dumped items of rubbish once
investigated and a collection is
requested by enforcement however we do
have to bear in mind that some items may
be dumped on private land and a more
lengthy enforcement process applies
which may unfortunately in the case in
some respects this time specifically in
the cases and Jones Road concerning
bulky waste I can report as follows a
dumped washing machine has been
collected by the Council for dumped
black refuse sacks have been collected
by Planet Council a pile of dumped
timber has been collected by sonic
Council a dumped mattress has been
collected by the council a dumped chair
has been collected by the council now
the above action should not have been
necessary necessary as there is a
corporation tip at half mile ride for
the disposal of bulky waste and if a
resident does not have transport the
council will dispose of such items with
a book collection surface at a small
charge
with respect to litter in the air of
Hawley square adding to Street Anson
Jones wrote generally it is there in the
first place because unfortunately there
are some people who do not dispose of
the litter responsibly the council and
I'm sure everyone else greatly
appreciates the actions of proactive
residents like yourself who take care of
the local environment and we hope that
seeing this helps to encourage others to
take more care and not to drop litter
and dump waste spoiling our otherwise
beautiful community Thank You chairman
Thank You councillor savage thank him
his wife Jen dried some seven questions
from members of the council no questions
have been received from members in
accordance with council procedure rule
40 move on to agenda item 8 motions have
noticed no motions on notice have been
received in accordance with the council
procedure rule 3 the gender rights of
nine leaders report I call upon the
leader council Bassett
Thank You chairman I'm pleased to
announce that tannic District Council
has been allocated an additional four
hundred and eighty three thousand pounds
and provisional funding from central
government under its rough sleeping
initiative the provisional allocation is
for twenty nineteen twenty and follows
an earliest successful bid for funding
we saw the district received three
hundred and seventy six thousand for a
range of initiatives aimed at rough
sleeping reduction for 2018-19 the final
allocation will be dependent on progress
made in the delivery of the 2018 program
and services the funding received to
date is being used to deliver support
for both new and entrenched rough
sleepers with a particular focus on
delivering tangible support which is
also tailored to each individual this
means tackling the many reasons people
struggle to find and then stay in
accommodation funding received has made
possible the launch of the Thanet rise
service rise standing for roughly four
intervention support and empowerment
which aims to work with those most in
need and address any underlying barriers
to finding and maintaining accommodation
the rise team undertake early morning
and late night outreach to verify people
who have been reported as rough sleeping
and work with them to develop a
personalized support plan to deal with
some of the reasons they may have
trouble staying in accommodation the
issue of rough sleeping is a complex one
and it's vital that these vulnerable
residents are given the widest possible
range of support the work we are doing
to assist the people who are sleeping
rough in sanik has already begun and is
clearly making a really big difference
the fact that we potentially have the
funds to continue that work for another
year is fantastic news additionally
following a recent visit the ministry of
housing communities and local government
wrote the tenets Council to say how
impressed they were with the progress
the cast had made this year in tackling
homelessness locally they were
particularly impressed with the fact
that the council now has no families
with children placed in temporary hotel
accommodation last month we hosted a
visit from five members of the House of
Lords Select Committee on regenerating
seaside towns and communities the
cross-section the cross party peers are
conducting the inquiry into the complex
challenges faced by seaside towns and
communities and requested a visit to
Margate as part of their returns
gathering members of the committee met
with senior counselors and officers from
the council as well as key partners from
the public sector and representatives
from the local business community their
objective was to understand some of the
challenges the area faces including
issues around housing as well as
examining the effects of regeneration
and the role of the visitor economy in
generating change the visit provided an
opportunity for the council to
demonstrate the positive impact of a
range of ongoing projects including the
live market housing intervention
programme the multi-agency task force
and the Dalby square regeneration scheme
this was achieved via a tour of key
sites in cliftonville in addition visits
to the Turner contemporary and Dream
Land were held to showcase examples of
successful regeneration in the town
being able to demonstrate the impact of
the work we're already undertaking and
the ongoing challenges we continue to
face in the area itself was unique and
welcome
anything then it is fortunate that in
recent years visitor growth has bucked
the national trend so we have a positive
story to tell that said we face
significant pockets of deprivation and
the related challenges that that brings
something many seaside towns and results
experience we are working hard to tackle
this but there is always more that can
be done and I'm hopeful that by working
together across government and the
public private and voluntary sectors we
can strengthen our approach and continue
to thrive as a coastal destination Lord
Bassam of Brighton who chairs the Select
Committee has said that the valuable
insights they gain from their visit will
play an important part in their inquiry
new rules came into play from Monday the
first of October 2018 which will require
more landlords to secure a licence for
houses in Multiple Occupation that they
rent out an HMI is a property that
contained more than one household
mandatory licensed innovation those came
into force in 2006 and originally
applied to properties of three or more
stories with five or more people living
in them most licensable properties
contain some shared kitchens bathrooms
and toilets the law is now changing but
most HMOs rented by five or more people
will now need a license irrespective of
how many stories there are in the
building HMOs adapter for occupants will
not be affected and normal some HMOs
which are self-contained flats within
larger purpose-built blocks but further
requirements will also come in force
which will set minimum sizes four
bedrooms in license of all HMOs the
changes are being introduced by
government to protect more HMO tenants
this will help ensure that landlords
make their health and safety obligations
and do not allow overcrowding to blight
people's lives we're an effective HMO
does not have a license
the landlord cannot use a section 1
notice to seek possession of the
property and evict tenants learners also
will be required to adhere to counsel
refuse schemes the measure is intended
to reduce antisocial behavior waste
associated with vais problems in HMOs
this will help reduce their impact and
will benefit neighbors and surrounding
communities if they haven't already done
so hm
landlords are urged to act now and apply
for a license affected landlords who
fail to apply for licenses by Monday the
first of October will be at risk of
criminal prosecution and unlimited court
fines additionally the council will have
the power to apply for a rent repayment
order and will soon also have the option
of issuing a civil penalty of up to
30,000 pounds following the question
asked at last council meeting about
Newgate shelter counselor Gregory has
met with councilor Dawson and the newly
formed friends of Cliftonville coastline
to discuss the procedure for a community
asset transfer this will be coming to a
future cabinet meeting for permission to
advertise for interested community
groups to come forward this week he also
signed a legal papers for KCC to
surrender the lease on their Center at
the Sibley Road building which is
adjacent to juice ins this has been
closed for some time but will now be
marketed on a short-term Litton basis
whilst various options are appraised for
the site to be used for a non Treasury
investment purpose probably small
industrial units which will provide a
substantial and sustainable income for
the council in the future in further
asset management news this year today
over 80 assets have now been transferred
to community groups town and parish
councils are sold on the open market
this reduces the cost liability to TDC
or brings in substantial cash receipts
for reinvestment in council services or
commercial opportunities a good example
of this is the sale of units at Hart's
down which sold for four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars last month also
saw a record-breaking number of
volunteers taking part in great british
beach Queens
though there were two events sorry can
we can we have that may well be the case
but we're going to listen to the leader
thank you I'll ask you to leave the
chamber if you carry on leader can you
carry on please Thank You chef last
month also saw a record-breaking number
of volunteers taking part in great
british beach claims there were two
events run by sonic coast project on
15th of september they were hugely
successful being attended by the largest
ever number of volunteers
insulted they're 163 volunteers on our
Saudi beach cleans a peg wall by over a
hundred volunteers collected 120
kilograms of Beach litter and a plum
pudding in minis by around 60 volunteers
collected a further 30 kilograms
additionally to G BBC surveys were
completed and submitted to the Marine
Conservation Society for their national
database and to see how our beaches are
faring over time these two beaches have
been monitored over the last 15 years
and they seem clearer and cleaner than
ever before but plastics remain the most
common items found in all this time the
efforts of these volunteers mean that
these beaches will be a lot cleaner for
our maritime marine and bird life as
well as our residents and visitors and
while speaking about visitors I'm
pleased to report that the Visitor
Information Center at droit house has
experienced its busiest summer since
opening in its current location figures
for this July and August show a 32%
increase rising footfall compared to
those in 2011 when it opened in total
there were over 28,000 contacts for July
and August 2018 this includes actual
visitors to the v.i.c as well as phone
calls and emails received beakers are
also up on the same time period last
year with footfall rising by 19% and
contacts rising by 10% a huge thanks
thank you is due to the dedicated staff
who helped to provide such a fantastic
service to our visitors and finally I'm
pleased to announce that our seasonal
public toilets are remaining open until
the end of October Thank You chair Thank
You leader
I call upon councillor Crowe Brown to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report councillor
crevalle
thank you lady fer Thank You chair for
comprehensive report I'm surprised a
leader hasn't mentioned the draft local
plan especially the disparate
distribution of houses from the largest
brownfield site in Fannett moving the
allocation to the residents the
burgeoning Westgate Hartsdale Minster
and Westwood
I'm sure he's enjoying dealing with the
numerous public comments as to why these
Harriers have been allocated until
program can we stick to the points
raised by the leader please
I think we've dealt with the local plan
and obviously the consultation is taking
place and we will assemble the comments
and no doubt those sort of comments will
be in that summary once we once we put
it together Thank You ruff sleeping it's
very good news indeed that so here the
council has been allocated an additional
government funding of 483 thousand
pounds dealing with rough sleeping and
it done it I've always considered our
housing department to be one of the top
performing departments in the council
I've had plenty of great dealings with
them and I wish them best to help with
this additional money in this dealing
with this complex situation I'm also
pleased to hear about a new repeat rows
regarding that coming to pay from Monday
the 1st of October which require more
landlords to secure a license for houses
a multiple opportunity our selective
licensing schemes in Margate and
Cliftonville are a key weapon in the
battle to improve standards in the
private rented sector we doubt landlords
putting tenants at risk and deal with
crime and anti-social behaviour and on a
final note in terms of tourism we are
delighted panic continues on an upward
trend estimated 4 million visitors every
year discovering exploring our fantastic
beaches our blue flag areas our villages
and heritage and thriving and growing
the cultural thing Thank You council
crow brown leader wish to respond I
don't think there's much to respond to
so I'll move on and I call upon
councillor Reverend hypoa to comment on
ask questions in relationship to the
leaders report councillor Piper Thank
You mr. chairman having got myself into
a little bit of trouble last time by
appearing to ask a question about which
the leader couldn't reply an answer this
evening I will start with a couple of
comments and then I have a couple of
questions please although it is not
necessarily asking you to reply this
evening but some reply for Abel
will be very helpful the news of further
funding for tackling homelessness and
other rough sleeping issues is indeed
very welcome this does however need to
be more than just a sticking-plaster I
think we're all aware that the demand is
increasing an extraordinary rate I'd
like to take this opportunity to
congratulate those multi-agency staff
and those counselors particularly Jenny
matter face and Lynn Fairbrass to name
just two who have been very busy working
together for more than a couple of good
years now with the winter shelter
program and other measures to try and
bring some help to those who are most
vulnerable the council indeed gets the
plaudits from the MHC LG which is good
but it is worth remembering the unspoken
heroes who take on nightshift support
and other services to help it's good to
hear that the House of Lords Select
Committee enjoyed their visit and we're
impressed by what they saw I'm gonna try
this one again it may be nice to invite
them to return to see what they missed
this time namely Ramsgate which is great
which leader has great need of their
gathered wisdom particularly the wisdom
they have so recently gathered from
Thanet the changes to HMO regulations
are much needed and one hopes will
provide genuine protection for
vulnerable tenants and perhaps in the
future changes for smaller HMOs will
also be forthcoming leader when someone
is particularly successful in sporting
achievement or has received numerous
awards for military service it is usual
to list those order those achievements
in order of prestige or seniority so one
can get a good idea of what's actually
been going on from your report leader it
says in further asset management news to
date over 80 assets have now been
transferred to community groups town and
parish councils or sold on the open
market this reduces the cost liabilities
to TDC or brings in substantial capital
receipts for reinvestment in council
services or commercial opportunities a
good example of this being the sale of
units
hearts down which sold for 450,000
pounds
they appear to be randomly listed and I
would hazard a guess leader that sale on
the open market may not be the least
significant method of asset disposal if
a good example is hot town please permit
me to ask for sometime in the future are
there any bad examples we should take
note of more seriously do we not to
mention the public ever really see where
the money goes
in terms of reinvestment in council
services all commercial opportunities
leader can I plead for a change of heart
on the Western on the cliff site which
includes the old motor house there has
been a dedicated team of local people
aided by celebrities and other investors
who have a real interest in bringing
forward project motor house if members
are not too aware of the plans I
recommend a quick read the site is in an
admittedly case of 5 are we going to
stick to the agenda that or the report
that the leader I think we all
sympathize with the situation your
outlining and perhaps that's that's a
subject for a future at the council
meeting but I don't think this evening
we need to be taught what has happened
in the past I think we're all aware of
the situation it's a very sad situation
and and for someone some what can I can
I speak to the counselor please sorry
can I speak to the council I was going
to say counts the piper as someone who
saw the Rolling Stones they are in the
past I find it very sad so I sympathize
with you but have you finished your
response chairman thank you there are
just a couple of really I believe
important points for the public it is
under the asset disposal heading that
the leader has introduced in his report
the sight is dangerous and if a happy
developer or prospector wins the open
auction for the site does the council
have any measures in hand to place a
guarantee the site will be made safe
immediately actually leader I was going
to ask
why can't we enter into some kind of
relationship with investors to project
motels so that we can keep that
wonderful asset if we do I'm sure it
will enhance the role of how you put it
in your report in quotes the visitor
economy generating change not just for
Ramsgate but for the whole of Thanet I
am disappointed leader that the Visitor
Information Center at Ramsgate which is
in custom-house just in case anybody is
unaware of where it is didn't want to
mention in the crowd congratulations for
those organizations bringing visitors
and helping visitors once they get here
thanking chair for allowing me to
continue that's quite all right and you
will note that the VI K kiosk in for all
stairs wasn't mentioned either leader
would you like to respond to a couple of
questions I think we're in it Thank You
chairman I mean I think first thing you
talked about the the rough sleeper
situation it is a growing problem and I
think the discounts always responded
with with its partners very positively
to the situation and I think the
seriousness of the problem and the
increase in nature of it is reflected in
the fact that government are looking to
give more money towards this problem and
hopefully we will use it effectively and
you mentioned a winter shelter and that
received a number of awards and you're
right for everybody that works in you
know volunteers there again deserves air
plaudits you asked for whether the laws
are going to come back and visit rams
guy having been to Margate it was out of
our control they specifically asked to
come to Margate and that was the way the
visit was structured but I can assure
you in the presentation that we gave to
the laws before we went on the tour
Ramsgate was indeed mentioned as indeed
other places in Fanny so they are aware
that we have issues in other parts of
the I'm not just in Margot and
cliftonville listeni Bassett disposals
no there was no hierarchy there
that was the list as it was given to me
so there we are
as far as Western and cliffs is
concerned yes I'm aware of the community
concern about this again I am led to
believe that the situation here is that
it was registered as a community asset
and as soon as that happens the council
is obliged to follow a legal process
which it has followed and I can tell you
no more than that I think that's a bad
hm thank you Thank You leader now in the
absence of councilor matter face I call
upon counselor Constantine to comment on
or ask questions in relationship to the
leaders report councillor Constantine
and if we can keep the questions thank
you to the leaders report thank you
fantastic that we're doing more for
rough sleepers action is very much
needed in Thanet we have more than
double the national average of rough
sleepers in fact rough sleeping has
grown by 169 percent since 2010 I don't
know what changed in 2010 and that rate
continues to rise tackling the causes of
rough sleeping is a little like trying
to tackle the causes of the current
mental health crisis and the crisis in
the provision of social care both of
which contribute hugely to rough
sleeping this government have done so
much to create rough sleeping poor
mental health and to struggling NHS we
are now trying to fix a broken society
with an ever decreasing budget and I
note that council funding will be cut by
a further 1.3 billion next year on the
topic of the rough sleeping and the rise
project could the leader tell me exactly
who rise are employing I'm very pleased
to hear that the visit by the MHC algae
was so successful I wonder if it was
pointed out to them that the prospect of
400 social homes which were available to
us from Stone Hill Park and much-needed
are actually now not available to us and
did you talk to them about the cuts to
our families budge
by the introduction of universal credit
the poorest families in our community
stand to lose 200 pounds per month we
know we've got 4 million children in
poverty and that is rising and we know
that we've got some of the poorest wards
in in Thanet Housing Benefit has been
frozen also constant I know I could be
very very generous but I think we're
wandering away from the leaders report
at the moment what are we doing to look
again at Housing Benefit so that many
more of our families can afflict can
afford accommodation properly I note
with interest that Lord's visit I'm glad
that that was a success I'm glad that
Ramsgate got a mention we would have
preferred a visit I have to tell you I
know that the Lord's was across the lake
I wondered why it wasn't cross party
indeed labour felt very left out and I
think that was very short-sighted of you
I know this government has pledged to
bit to pledge 2 billion pounds to fund
the building of social housing and to
scrap the limit on how much councils can
boring the challenge for you is to an
identify that you're wandering against
for Constantine is this is an agenda
item for a future it could avoid rough
sleepers I'm pleased of course that it
continued please and please of course
that we have no families now in
temporary coma in temporary
accommodation hotel accommodation
however we do still have families out of
area we do still have children taken
away from their social and support
networks and we do still have children
who are not getting access to the
education that they rightfully deserve
I'm wondering what we are doing to
address that issue
I'm surprised when you thanked the
employees leader that you didn't also
thank the volunteers at the volunteer
information center many of whom worked
very very hard and pleased at visitors
to Ramsgate and elsewhere our rises I'm
also pleased that the public toilets
will be kept open until the end of
October but they will need cleaning more
regularly
there were some deficiencies in the
report in particular the seven seventy
thousand pounds that residents paid for
the aveer report was not submitted to
pins and should have been submitted to
pins and with regard to the so the STP
council Wells formed an executive
scrutiny committee to look at the East
Kent trust
today the CQC named and shamed think one
who in the game councillor Constantine I
keep saying that I can be as generous as
anything but can you please wind up we
may well hear some of this in the
scrutiny reports which follow I just
wanted to point out that East Kent has
been cited as one of the worst for
providers in the country and you can bet
your bottom dollar will be at the bottom
of the bottom and I also wondered what
the leader was doing with regard to the
stroke service and last but not least
assets in Fallot are indeed the family
silver while other councils are busy
acquiring assets and building up a
portfolio why well Baalak borrowing is
cheap
why are sanic following that lead could
the leader answer that question thank
you
Thank You councillor Constantine I
didn't realize we were already in an
election I thought that was next May
leader would you like to respond yeah I
thank you chairman as as expected
council constantine delivered a speech
rather than comment on on my report or
ask questions there of he just just pick
up just know because I'm not going to
get into items of national policy and so
on I'm here to talk about what happens
here in San Lee just a couple of points
on there I gather that you talked about
that there are families that are homes
that are housed outside the area but I
understand that these families are
brought back as quickly as possible into
Thanet I think where the rough sleeping
numbers of concern I'm not sure what
number you gave but I'm advised that as
of the
third of October we had 40 rough
sleepers which i think is fewer than the
number that you quoted there as far as
investment is concerned yes you're
absolutely right we I can assure you
that we as a council are looking into
opportunities that may exist for in
investment but as you will know that the
counselors have to be very very prudent
in what they do so we're not going to be
running into things thank you and glad
you appreciate that thank you very much
okay please I'll have the public gallery
cleared if we can't get through this
meeting civilized can I just say
Chairman's role I'm slightly
disappointed there are so many
supporters of councilor Venables because
it hasn't left enough room for my fan
club from Ramsgate Paul but there we are
thank you
Thank You leader no you can't--no you've
had no sorry sorry point of order you've
had your say thank you I'm moving on to
agenda item 10 which is a report to the
chairman of the executive policy and
Community Safety scrutiny panel
I call upon councilor to collect Glenn
Coleman cook to present the report
councillor Coleman cook Thank You mr.
chairman the executive scrutiny panel
mess on the 27th of September where we
discussed the museum's asset management
report and the food loss service plan
and enforcement policy on the food loss
service plan enforcement policy report
we recommended the policy for adoption
by the council and proposed that the
council identified funding for staff
training and additional staffing in
order to effectively deliver the highly
needed statutory service on the asset
management Thanet museums report we
requested cabinet to establish when the
50,000 funds bequeath to dickens house
will be made available to be used for
the maintenance of the museum and where
the TDC had the right to dispose of the
building
although the panel plans discuss the
crime statistics in sanik report from
the Community Safety Partnership it will
now get the report on the 13th of
November meeting under the new scrutiny
Arrangements the executive the scrutiny
panel is responsible for callings and
executive decisions but since my last
report and their callings
we made to the panel I look forward to
continuing to work with the cabinet
offices to make our decision making
process stronger for the benefit of our
district thank you Thank You councillor
and agenda right sorry
councillor Johnson you have a question
yes thank you thank you chairman of that
committee unfortunately you weren't
there was a bleach aired by councillor
Curran and I have looked at the report
that's going to cabinet that followed
that meeting and I'm a little
disappointed that it's not clear how
strongly we felt about a number of
issues particularly the Margate museum
the Mara spoiler thank you for
mentioning the 50,000 pounds that is jus
really and long bequeathed to the
Dickens museum because that means
resolving that counsel seems to be
dragging their heels on those efforts
but I felt on the night that we had a
good hearing cross-party about the
Margate marah's parlor that the mayor
wished to return urgently to that parlor
our mayor even came and spoke herself
that evening and so I don't think the
report to cabinet is strong enough about
what we decided that night the other
point that I raised was under the food
section because with brexit and the
changes that are coming forward it said
there were no financial implications for
the council in that report on that night
and the officer did agree that she
realized she should have said there will
be financial implications we're going to
need to train new staff we're going to
have to look at the what's coming from
national government once brexit is
implemented
so as I say or torches you weren't there
but we did have a very good meeting
Abele chaired I substituted for
councillor and Campbell and was able to
particularly raise the issues of the
museums and I don't think the Cabinet
report quite matches what we decided
that night and the chair over there is
not anything Thank You counsel Johnson
and I'm sure your comments will be taken
on board by both the chairman of that
committee and the vice chairman thank
you agenda item 11 reported the chairman
of the finance budget and performance
scrutiny panel I call upon the
councillor Linda Piper to present report
council Piper
our committee has not met at since I
last reported to members at the last
council meeting I mentioned that we were
going to receive a full report
concerning Fort Punk port finances at
our October meeting and a report about
stannic residents being in temporary
accommodation at the following meeting
I'd like to encourage members to attend
the future finance budget and
performance scrutiny meetings I also
invited members to write to me if there
is a topic on which they would like our
committee to have a presentation and
this evening I would repeat that
invitation and ask that emails are
copied to mr. Charles hung we thank you
Jeff Thank You Kayla Piper agenda item
12 constitutional changes changes to
contract procedure rules
I call upon councillor Gregory
councillor Gregory Thank You chairman
this report covers the review and
updating of the council's contract
Standing Orders the council's contract
standard orders set out and minimum
obligations to be met by spending
officers when purchasing goods works or
services on behalf of the authority they
periodically require revisions and meet
the changing needs of the business and
changes in legislation as you'd expect
some changes are purely housekeeping
such as updating job titles of
responsible officers but there are other
more substantive changes these include
the introduction of an e tendering
system changes in procurement
legislation and the introduction of the
general data protection regulations
there also greater reporting and
transparency obligations that the
council now has a do especially duty to
meet under the local government
transparency code these changes are
listed within the report at 2.1 and
referenced to the contract Standing
Orders number as contained in annex 1
also highlighted in the report is the
realignment of spending thresholds to
those of our neighboring authorities
canterbury dover Folkston and highs to
provide consistency of approach across
the East Kent authorities this helps
enable the standardization of processes
with our supplies and contractors with
consistent spend
how's that assist with collaborative
working when undertaking joint
procurements it also simplifies the role
of shared services such as these can
housing and agent services when those
organizations are involved in
procurements on behalf of the East Kent
districts the revision of the contract
standing orders has been presented to
the constitutional review Working Party
which requested three amendments
included a paragraphs 3.1 to 3.3 of this
report Standards Committee then endorsed
the revisions requested by the working
party and I move that Council approves
the recommendation in paragraph 4.1 and
adopts contract standing orders in annex
1 as revised by the recommendations of
the constitutional review Working Party
and the Standards Committee thank you
chairman Thank You councillor Gregory is
there a seconder thank you do members
agree I'm sorry
councillor Johnson thank you very much
chairman obviously we take very
seriously our Constitution as a council
and people who work on the
constitutional working party go with
through the agenda and through the hope
the items with a fine-tooth comb when
the report came to the standards
committee the officer putting the report
to us chose not to push for people who
work for this council and subcontracted
State at having a living wage for their
staff and we argued throughout the
evening that what the constitutional
Working Party had recommended must go we
were supported by the Standards
Committee cross-party should not be
ignored
we should not overturn what the
constitutional working party had
recommended to us and I would like to
make sure and say it again here this
evening that where we contract out
subcontract work from this council that
the people that we deal with pay their
employees a living wage and we asked and
we asked and in Japan there were there
was a lot of pressure on us that night
not to agree that I hope that you are
I'm sure you are listening and that no
one tries to overturn our decisions
thank you
councillor Gregory to respond because I
believe all of that is in the report
yeah it says Thank You councillor
Johnston in 3.1 there's a recommendation
there that consideration is given to
inclusion of a provision to require
contractors to pay the national living
wage so we're adopting that so there are
the three recommendations 3.1 3.2 3.3
that we're adopting tonight no I'm sorry
councillor Campbell next council candle
yeah just to support councillor Johnson
at the actual working party we actually
insisted and I think it was unanimous
that we include within the actual
contract negotiations that we would in
future only to work with organizations
and suppliers that provided the living
wage to their employees not just a
living wage to our employee he's been
living wage to the suppliers and
contractors that we contract that went I
think to the standards committee and I
can cancel a Johnson please read through
the status committee I think also that
if we are going to actually work towards
contract as a living wage that you
should be time scaled shouldn't be an
open-ended you know sometime in the
future perhaps never without to actually
work towards this there should be a time
scale it actually put with it so that we
will actually achieve it at a given time
thank you fails handle councillor
Gregory have done anything to respond to
them Thank You chairman yeah my
understanding I have to say is that we
have a legal requirements for our
contractors to pay the living wage over
25 and we have a minimum wage to pay
from 21 to 25 in from 18 to 20 and for
apprentices and so on and this is all
over overseen by a HMSO so it should
already be happening in all honesty I
mean this is just us putting into our
performance certain standards and what
should already be happening in all
honesty
Thank You councillor Gregory
now can I carry on I'm sure we're all
eagerly awaiting for the next agenda
item Cheers
general item 13 oh sorry we need to we
need to agree that sorry I got to a
seconder and do members agreed secondly
you haven't put an amendment forward no
can I put it to the vote all those in
agreement are we any against thank you
gender item 13 declaration of agency
Margate Central Ward now can I
councillor Johnson we're not showcasing
here are this is this valid point are we
chairman chairman Chairman I have
neither the time nor the inclination to
showcase on this item the residents of
my Ward which is one of the most elusive
points Lord it is a point of order it is
the first time in my 24 years that I
have seen a vacancy announced at a
council meeting like this it's the first
time in my 24 years for a councillor is
named where he's supposed to be an
employee of this council he should not
be on white it should be on pink so
therefore I'm telling you and advising
you of the information I have from the
Labour Party solicitor and the Labour
Party Council this item should be
withdrawn we are walking up a very
dangerous path as councillors if we
support this I'm asking please that this
item I'm proposing that this item is
withdrawn the lawyers are locked in
battle on this one and if it ever goes
to a vote I want a recorded vote because
I don't want my name tarnished with what
this decision is councillor Venables
councillor Venables is working for the
forward trust not this council and this
is a total misinformation and I'm sorry
but our solicitor has advised that the
report is full of errors and this
evening I'm with her permission I have
clicked it to every member in this room
who
say they haven't been told that they are
being asked to vote for something that
is untrue
thank you second eighth point of order
point of order I have not introduced the
item yet and as you will know councillor
Johnson from a meeting we had yesterday
this council has a statutory requirement
to have this item on the agenda in the
way that is being published so the item
is the Declaration of vacancy Margate
Central Ward I call upon we have quiet I
want to get this agenda item through as
in a civilized way I understand there's
a understand there's a lot of passion in
the room I can be very very passionate
but I need to get this meeting through
in an orderly fashion so I now call upon
Sophia naughty point of Orden this is a
point of order is it chair it is a point
of order I would like to know what what
breach of the section.80 of the Local
Government Act 1972 in Venables is
responsible for it's very clear about
disqualifications it says either
employed directly which we all
understand the terms of it then goes on
to say are employed by a company which
is under the control of the local
authority that is not the situation here
that is not the case it is wrong-footed
I propose we look again at this
my understanding is that the lawyers are
in fact looking at those very points
outside this meeting but it's not for
this meeting I need I am NOT sorry I
need to get this item through I need if
I can't get this item through I will
clear the public gallery I will ask for
a five-minute recess
I need the legal officer to explain the
situation so fear not I'm sorry I can
start shouting as loudly as you can
count so fear not naughty can you
explain the situation and if I can't
have silence will clear the public
gallery is this a point of order and
it's not a point of order that we've
already covered thank you because if I
quite what you said the lawyers are
looking at it now if it is the case I do
think but it is in the interest of this
council to leave this matter alone until
the lawyers have decided what the real
situation is otherwise we are taking
this council into very dangerous that's
not a point of order legal officer to
explain the situation thank you as the
report explains mr. Venables lost his
qualification to be a counsellor when he
took up a second role with the council
this report is not concerned with how or
why that happened the disqualification
has happened the effects of the
disqualification would apply whether or
not the actions which resulted in the
disqualification were done in good faith
and or without the knowledge of the
effects of section 18 of the Local
Government Act in 1972
section 80 simply operates to disqualify
someone who falls within its terms as a
matter of law under Section 86 of the
Local Government Act 1972 where a
counselor ceases to be qualified to be a
counselor the law requires that the
council shall declare the office to be
vacant
so the council has no choice in the
matter it has to declare the vase sorry
can we let the legal officer speak
please if this continues I'll have to
clear the public gallery I'm sorry just
listen to the legal officer listen to
the argument and then take that concern
elsewhere please I'll repeat that
section that last section again under
Section 86 of the Local Government Act
1972 where a councillor ceases to be
qualified to be a counsellor the law
requires that the council shall declare
the office to be vacant so the council
has no choice in the matter it has to
declare the vacancy in the Margate
central ward councillor Campbell have we
got a point of order y'all have a point
of order yes from just what the legal
officer has just said I'm I don't hold
what the legal officer said in
contention at all it's the fact that
whether or not councillor Venables has
been fairly disqualified if he has been
fairly disqualified then yes the council
is legally obliged to actually note the
vacancy but my our contention is he has
not been legally disqualified under
Section 80 of that particular report
Varley Chairman I'd like to come back on
that point regarding disqualification
this report is not regarding
disqualifications it's simply to declare
the vacancy if there is if if mr. if mr.
Venables feels that there is an issue
regarding disqualification there is a
separate Avenue for him to pursue this
particular Avenue is within your gift is
members to make this decision to declare
the vacancy it's not regarding
disqualification I understand that there
are issues regarding disqualification
which has been brought forward by other
lawyers but not by the counsel if that
needs to be explored that will be
explored separately to this process
so what you're being asked to do this
evening members is to declare the
vacancy one final point before I put it
to the meeting council Piper Thank You
chairman Thank You chairman I'm it's not
a point of order but I'm responding to
the to your notes that we received
yesterday that said quite clearly this
item may be debated in the usual way I
would like to ask for some formal
recognition given the information that's
out there in the public domain that this
decision has nothing to do with any
impropriety on the path of Ian's
Venables that this is a situation that
has been done to him and therefore we
should note that he has not misbehaved
in any way shape or form and that yes
the council is now using the legal
situation to get this notice out there
because it has no choice it has to do it
this evening but it leaves a very very
bad taste in the mouth and I really do
ask I'm sure on behalf of everybody that
it's record recognized that the
Inventables has done nothing wrong if
you cancel south of fire we'll respond
chairman on that point I would just like
to give my advise that you cannot add an
additional note this is simply regarding
the vacancy so any notes would have to
be around that vacancy not regarding the
disqualification thank you I'm now going
to put the proposal to the council sorry
we we debate after I put the proposal I
propose that council 1 notes that iam
Venables I'm sorry look if I was a
referee out of the issue 12 yellow cards
and I'm just about to get my red card
out and send people out the chamber
counts the Hayden when we become
counselors we sign a form saying if we
got any anything to do with the council
I'm serving the council being as
employee of the council I'm sure
councilor X councillor Venables has done
that and of course can we can we talk
through the chair I'm getting very
impatient that piece of paper chairman
and quite frankly that's what should
happen if the anybody
contravenes and starts working for the
council and they should vacate the
council there will be a council in next
May I think House of X counts of
Venables can put his name forward as a
member and of course they will have to
give up his work with the council thank
very much Kevin
Thank You council hey it and that wasn't
a point of order that was part of the
debate which will take place I now need
to put this proposal in the order that
we have the opportunity of debating it
so the proposal is one that the council
notes that year availables has become
disqualified form being a member of this
authority and two that the council
declares as vacant the office held by
inventables as a counselor for the
Margate central ward with the vice
chairman second our second that chair
I say again that we have a statutory
requirement to have this on the agenda
and get this matter under way can I
assume that councilors would wish to
continue the debate I'd like to get on
with the vote so that we can get things
moving but Kelso Johnson thank you very
much chairman thank you for your time on
this the reporter is actually full of
errors mr. Venables it says in the
report applied for and has taken up a
second meant with the council councilor
hatin he did not apply for the job the
council got the funding which we've been
told about earlier in the evening for
homeless people the council decided to
work with the forward trust councillor
Venables is an employee of the forward
trust this council invited the forward
trust to recommend somebody for the
position in the rise team they
recommended their best person 25 years
experience he's employed by the forward
trust he sits with the forward trust and
he works with the counsel team here the
lawyers and the counsel for the Labor
Party are very clear that this sort of
case has been tested before and they're
very clear that Ian Venables has an
extremely strong case against this
country against this council and there
are many others going on which is
causing me great embarrassment as a
councillor I'm sticking to the item
we must stop making mistakes this
council asked the forward trust they
asked particularly for Ian Ian took on
the job in good faith not only that but
he asked was it okay to take it on the
forward trust asked was it okay if he
was still a councillor and eat they were
told it was okay I came in on numerous
occasions to see mr. house I had to
explain to him what it was about because
he didn't really know an awful lot about
it come cuddle monk I'm sorry everybody
we need to get this out cut a long story
short he was running to and fro trying
to get the right information and with
mrs. cast Ravenna
cancer matter face up to a week before
he was saying it's still a gray area and
the next thing all of our counselors
were told were told that this item was
coming on the 11th
Jenny didn't know he was declaring that
Ian was disqualified Ian is only
disqualified because this council have
got it wrong
ian is employed by the forward trust
that's the name on his pay slip that's
who guides his work in this group that
he's got the government are looking and
the civil servant is looking at what
you're doing with the money they've
given you and they're very quick to take
it back if you don't spend it right and
I'm telling you we are getting the best
advice on this now what I have asked the
leader is where is the counsel advice
now the other day you told me you hadn't
seen it I think every time you speak to
an officer in this council you need to
see in writing what they're telling you
thank you you counsel Johnson there was
a fair amount of hearsay there I wasn't
there I get more advice from I get my
advice from officers and as I keep
saying this is a statutory requirement
to get this room counselor Constantine
are we not going to go over the same
ground because I'd like to get the vote
going
I'd like to defend my colleague council
iris because I've seen Miss Johnson
start very sorry I'll start again I
would like to support my colleague
counselor I miss Johnson because I've
seen that memo and she's exactly
correcting what she's saying so that's
the first thing just as an aside to this
I've been 25 years employed as a
professional trade union officer part of
my daily job is to advise members when
they have a difficulty the first thing I
have to do when if somebody comes to me
who is a member of my trade union and
has a difficulty is I have to ascertain
who their employer is how do I do that I
look at who they are paid by in this
case in Venables is paid by forward who
are their terms and conditions with in
this case in Venables terms and
conditions are with the forward trust
he is an employee of the fall would
trust what I say is if it looks like a
duck quacks like a duck it's a duck this
decision is the dock in Venables is an
employee of the forward trust and should
not be disqualified under Section 18
should not be Thank You councillor
Constantine I think we've already heard
that they are some procedural issues
that need to be looked in outside this
and council chamber council council
haten thank you very much chairman
people that were there councillors over
there seem to think that they haven't
signed that piece of paper I was talking
about we all have to sign that and I
dear to what these are times in sight
and quite frankly is no good Chatham you
down you've got this Ravel here that I
don't got to hear what you're saying
quite frankly when I'm talking they're
talking but when you're talking they're
quiet because they they like what you
what you called okay right Thank You
councillor Hayden I am now in a position
where I need to get on with the vote and
anymore from the public gallery I will
issue that final warning we will have a
recess and we will clear the fire the
public gallery so I'm going to put it to
the vote but before we do can i council
campbell to it sorry request a recorded
vote
if more than 50% of the members agree
I'm quite happy to have a recorded vote
do members agree on a recorded vote if
you can put your hands up if you do
hold them high so we can have account
those against those against
abstentions right we will have a
recorded vote Kelsey cable and you'll
notice that I didn't need to use my
casting vote right before we vote leave
the mic on before we move to the vote I
would just like to clarify what we are
voting for and I also like to say that I
did receive requests that this item
would be removed from the agenda and I
have to say that that is not within my
gift we have to get it on the agenda
this evening we have to go through this
procedure so I understand that there is
concern over circumstances surrounding
council availables disqualification as a
councillor however council tonight is
not being asked to decide whether or not
he has been disqualified that
disqualification has happened by all
operation of the law that position is
supported by the monitoring officer and
the council that has been providing
advice t it is it is open to mr.
Venables to challenge that
disqualification in the courts once a
counselor has been disqualified the law
requires the council forthwith declare
his office to be vacant can I just read
this I'm sorry right
okay councillors we're going to have a
five-minute recess while I clear the
public gallery you had your opportunity
to see how a recorded vote but I want
the public gallery cleared thing right
well thanks familiar round of applause
I'm obliged on obliged to give you one
more opportunity to leave the chamber so
if you won't leave the chamber and you
are verbally refusing to leave the
chamber
is that the case in that case I'm
adjourn in the meeting we will
reassemble on Monday thank you good
night and I'm sorry counselors for the
inconvenience
please be standing for the chairman of
Senate District Council
please be seated
goody good evening members and officers
of the council I welcome you to this
continuation of the meeting of the
council held on Thursday last the 11th
of October pleased to see as many
members have managed to make it
including councilor wells I have to say
looking very very relaxed I'll have to
remember to leave my tie off next time I
have to go through the housekeeping or
even though there's this is a
continuation if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices down
the stairs however through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the 4a please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber the Proceedings of this
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the Internet
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls in the
chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress
[Applause]
agenda item 1 which is in fact to the
continuation of the situation we had on
Thursday so it's continuation of agenda
item 13 declaration of vacancy Margate
central ward I can't call upon mr. house
director of corporate covenants and
deputy monitoring officer thank you
Thank You chairman members before we
move to the vote I just like to clarify
what counsel are being asked to vote
upon this evening whilst understand
there's been much discussion over the
circumstances surrounding accounts
available as disqualification has
counselor counselor tonight is not being
asked to decide whether or not he has
been disqualified since that
disqualification has happened by
operation of law it is of course open to
its availables to chain that
disqualification in the courts if he
thinks fit however what
council has been disqualified the law
requires I emphasize that point the law
requires that accounts are forthwith
declare his office to be vacant there is
no discretion to be exercised by the
council tonight on that matter so
council tonight is simply being asked to
carry out its legal duties under Section
86 of Local Government Act 1972 to
forthwith declare a vacancy for
counselor in the Margate central ward
Thank You chairman Thank You councillor
Constantine has her hand up is this C
point of order it is a point order can
you can you first refer to the point of
order that you're going to speak on I
can't actually
I can't refer to the point or drop in
that case in - you can quote it word for
word it's not a point of order it was on
procedure you've never asked me to quote
this before you didn't ask me to quote
this that the other night you need to be
consistent chair in your approach you
need to ask every member of this chamber
to quote word-for-word the point of
order whenever anybody brings a point of
order my point is this if we're
rehearsing rehashing why we're here then
we also need to rehearse and realism to
some of the arguments and some of the
detail we know we've had this is a this
isn't a simple application of law know
that come on just recognizes a mistake
in the making and I would be remiss as a
counselor if I didn't bring that this is
not going to hold her and can I just
speak over you and say but procedurally
we have gone through the debate we have
had the motion put before the members it
has been seconded we've had a vote to
have a recorded vote when they are at
the position following the recorded vote
where it was necessary to clear the
public gallery we can now move on to the
recorded vote unless you have a valid
point of order Thank You chair if you
could in future treat everybody with the
same seriousness if I have to quote word
for word then I would expect you to that
with all members in this chamber I will
indeed in fact has rarely come up in
this chamber a whilst I've been sitting
in this chair I don't
that this is a application of law I
believe this is a mistake
councillor Campbell Thank You chair yes
this is a clarification of the of the
Constitution I would like to know
whether or not members who weren't
present at the previous meeting on
Thursday and therefore never heard the
debate are allowed to vote tonight
without the without the advantage of
listening to the debate that took place
one let's run office who will respond
obviously members can decide themselves
where they feel they're fully informed
but I will point out this is a
procedural motion which is a legal
requirement is simply a step and then
administrative step the council must
take once the member is disqualified so
there is an issue about discretion or
points for or against what the law says
is that once a councillor has been
disqualified then forthwith the council
must declare the post of the position to
be vacant so there's not an issue about
debates about weighing up the balance of
different issues it is what the law says
and what the law requires and that would
encourage you as your monetary officer
that you should follow the law and
declare the post to be vacant Thank You
councillor Wales well again the same
spirit some clarification there's a
couple things there I think I was rather
interested to receive an invite to this
meeting because that was my
understanding I think it was cancelled
waivers understanding from a very long
time if you hadn't taken part of debate
that you would not normally vote all
right secondly the situation isn't quite
I think as much describes it because
actually the point before us tonight
it is indeed which is a request for
clarification of the position because
what he's put before us tonight is a
consequence of the disqualification and
if there's a doubt in anybody's mind in
this chamber that this qualification is
accurate or not and we have only seen
one legal advice on this it's not is one
that tells us no because your legal
advice sir gone from counsel is
apparently secret not to be shared and
there is there is a situation here where
what happens in terms of clarification
if we don't pass this
procedural and if that is their overall
been some way what bad are we doing it
thank you monitoring autism were the
council to brief section 86 there live
comes that and not declare the post
vacant as is required by law that I
think is marketing officer I'd have to
consider that decision
it's lawfulness if necessary compiler
monitor officers report about that
lawfulness and right back to a future
meeting respond to that like I think
that would be I mean very sensible I'm
being as patient and giving everyone the
opportunity now this is point of order
and the only point of order and I can be
patient I'm not asking you for word for
word but I mean it needs to be a point
of order that relates to the
Constitution counselor brim thank you
sure I find it very difficult to take
this seriously when the monitoring
officer doesn't even cut carry out the
own Constitution it's not democratic I
don't think you're fit for purpose tim
has no we don't want any personal
comment sorry chairman I think you want
to make some comment about that
I think it's wholly inappropriate I say
the appropriate remember to act like
this in this chamber and you should
consider where you ought to stay here
thank you girls for johnson i know you
had your hand up early on this i know
this will be a point of order because
you know the constitution thank you
thank you very much and actually i'll
have raised this on a number of
occasions with colleagues that the
constitution needs a complete overhaul
those of us who those of us who are on
standards have been challenging and
asking questions as of people on the
constitutional working party and we
might not have been here tonight if
there was an issue covered about
secondments in the constitution but it's
you may hide behind point of order but
you've actually had a letter today from
the labor party solicitor that you need
to share you also need to share casa
johnson enough about legal proceedings
and if i've received anything of a legal
matter
retain in my memory it will be private
and confidential and when it goes to a
legal situation you don't take sides
I've got to stay impartial okay I'm not
interested and this is not a point of
order thank you very much order is if
the new member is in here tonight who
weren't here on Thursday and didn't hear
the debate the same applies to mr. house
who was not here on Thursday and didn't
hear the debate so we're in it we're in
a catch-22 position with mr. house
because he didn't hear the debate now my
real point of order is the Jews must
tell us what you must tell us mr. house
what counsel advice was to you why is it
not attached to our agendas we need to
read it before we vote on something so
important and you certainly should be
sharing what the labour party solicitor
has sent today to protect all of us to
protect this counsel we need to have
every bit of information in front of us
and I certainly think that we should
withdraw this item again I'm sorry no no
no they've got you're making a you're
making a statement it's no it's not you
know we'll come back to this the women
if you're still with us will respond to
you think thank you chairman I'm not
going to sponsor to councillor Johnson
well I don't I don't think that there
was a point of order but that's for you
to judge and what I do want to to say is
that what councillor brim just said in
relation to an officer is completely
unacceptable from an officer's point of
view and hopefully for most members
points of view as well although they
need to make their own judgement on that
I just hope that no member will consider
that to be acceptable behavior in a
public meeting again because it
absolutely isn't to make personal
comments about the professional
integrity of individual officers Thank
You chef
I'll allow you your hands up thank you I
do have a dilemma here if there's points
of order or not it must be because we
might find ourselves in a situation
where this council decided that
councillor van de Bourgh's is
disqualified and we have a by-election
of new members elected and yet we have
also of course this side that councillor
Venable should not have been
disqualified so we end up with two
members elected for the same ward now
this is why it would be so important to
get the council advice from mr. house
but we know exactly where we stashed not
a point of order and we haven't got to
that stage yet Thank You councillor
Willis thank you I'm promoting people
again I'd been called counselor before
chairman oh now I'm not sure I consider
information thank you I just just want
to make the point just to emphasize once
again that two councillors just to try
and be helpful unless it's a point of
order in accordance with our
Constitution then then we're ready to
move to the to the next item of business
which is for the recorded vote on the
motion at hand
thank you we can move to the recorded
vote
I will have my knuckles rapped by being
far too liberal
is it a point of order it's for
clarification of what we're being asked
to do this evening am I allowed to get
an answer for that that's not a point of
order the monotron officer has already
explained what the vote means and what
we're doing here this evening
I think I'll read the motion again but
it already has been seconded and as I
said the start we've already voted to
have a recorded vote so I'd like to move
on to the recorded vote but I will read
the motion and the motion says council
they fit I don't be difficult but I mean
you know you know what these things are
like well you know if we
get it right then Ben there's issues and
counts the world asked a question some
time ago which I think was a reasonable
one which I do agree with that you know
it does seem odd to me that if this is a
continuation of a meeting that members
that weren't here shouldn't really be
allowed to vote on this matter and I
wonder why they've been invited to come
back quite honestly
thank you Mangla officer can you respond
on that I have the same query all
members invited the council meetings and
sometimes members can't be here at the
start and they'll come to a meeting
later on but in this particular instance
this is an administrative proposal
there's not a matter about discretion
plethora T we're listening to debate of
a matter it's actually relevant at all
so that's why particularly in this
particular case which is where it's a
legal obligation on the council to
declare this vacancy the issue about
whether they're thoroughly debate of a
matter is not relevant so I think it is
appropriate for members who were who
weren't here last week that they could
vote on the matter and being to pursue
patient on the insole but the world
ellika matters everyone we're prepared
to listen to it's very simple question
that's what I'm just like turn on stew
which is that if this is a consequence
of disqualification the counselor could
an officer please explain to me why
councillor van der waals was invited to
this meeting
I was not aware he had been invited
amazing if he had that would have been
an error so that doesn't affect the
disqualification yeah thank you for that
admission can we go on to the admission
about the letter that was written by
this council advising employers that
this wasn't gonna happen I'm not aware
of that letter I need to go to the vote
I will read the motion out four members
one the council notes that iam Venables
has become disqualified for being a
member of this Authority and two
declares as vacant the office held by
iam Venables as a counselor for the
Margay Central Ward I'd now like to move
on to the recorded vote if I'm a
councillor Ashby counts AB a fir'd
counts a Braidwood
council brim Casa Buckley that's a
Campbell Casa Glenn Coleman cook absent
council Keith Coleman cook Catholic
honor that's a constant time count sacra
brown NASA Dawson absent cows a day
Casa della Casa Dennis Kelso Dexter
that's a Dixon cancer Edwards after
Evans Kelso Jeremy Fairbrass that's a
Lynne Fairbrass that's a falcon that's a
Fenner cancer game Casa Gregory
that's a Grove counselor Hillman
that's a Jay Jones
that's a Johnston now to Larkins absent
got a Marten counter Parsons casalinda
Piper
that's a Stewart piper casalinda Potts
counselor Roy Potts gossip you not
present
Casa Rogers that's her as ecchi casts of
David Saunders Castlemaine Saunders
that's a savage cancer shunk cancer
Taylor
that's a Tomlinson casts a town end
there's a Wells Casa right
right that motion was lost 13 for 27
against and one abstention right we can
move on to the next item on the agenda
which is agenda item 2 yes we can
item 14 changes to committees panels and
boards 2018-19 I am told it is relevant
proportionality I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect of the
options as outlined in the report counts
the Beaufort Sharon I am afraid that
I've got to agree with you know the
mutterings from the floor I don't
actually see that this really follows
because council hasn't actually declared
the vacancy so if the post isn't vacant
by definition it must be Phil Riggs risk
of completing two things here one is
earlier item was to declare the vacancy
to cause an election to be held
we should refused to do that I'll be
utley have no legal power to the earth
the least issue about it doesn't affect
the disqualification of the councillor
the counts are still disqualified so you
still have a reduction in the number of
councillors mr. chairman can I propose
that we put this idea to one side until
such time as we have certainty about
disqualification whether there is a
vacancy monitoring officer to respond
and I don't know why there isn't
certainty I am the council's monetary
officer they have illegal services legal
services I have obtained legal advice
and counsel which confirms that council
venerables has been disqualified
I have no grounds to reconsider that
advice I've received representation
from other parties none of which made me
change my mind in terms of the legal
provisions regarding these modifications
and section 80 the local government and
I sent it to so in that on that basis
there is no legal doubt your councils
Heather legal your counsel monetary
officer is telling you that counselor
Venables is disqualified in terms of the
law and therefore it's appropriate to
move on to agenda item 2 oblique 14 to
consider the composition of the council
Elsa Campbell point of order no a
proposition I propose the set aside as
agenda items or later date until the
clarity of the suspended counselor is
made clear
can we have a five minute the German we
now resume four minutes not five minutes
Kelso Beauford Thank You chairman I move
that this item be deferred to a future
meeting thank thank you members and
apologies for calling you back this
evening that now concludes the business
I'll sorry I know this is a foregone
conclusion do members agree that wasn't
as good as the sing song on Thursday was
it that now concludes the business of
the meeting this evening 7:25 thank you